I have a second podcast now. Do you know about this? I don't and I feel betrayed. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 34 recorded on June 26, 2021. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about a plethora of topics including std tuple and other tuple types, std array, APL, and so much more. I saw that you were on, like, I saw a tweet where there was a screenshot of you and, like, some other people on some panel at some programming language conference. There's a bunch of things.
我现在有了第二个播客。你知道这事吗？我不知道，而且我觉得被背叛了。欢迎收看ADSP播客，第34期节目，录制于2021年6月26日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的共同主持布莱斯（Bryce）将讨论大量的主题，包括std tuple和其他tuple类型、std array、APL等等。我看到你上了，呃，我看到一条推特，上面有你和一些其他人一起在某个编程语言会议的小组讨论中的截图。有很多事情。
You're on panels it wasn't a panel it was an impromptu conversation um uh let's i'm gonna get well so what are all the things to announce because i we do such a bad job of promoting stuff in general um so one I was on I'm doing an ask me anything next Friday July 2nd at I don't remember the time but there's Twitter details I'm doing an ask me anything
你在小组讨论里。那不是小组讨论，那是一次即兴谈话。嗯，呃，让我想想，我要开始——那么，所有要宣布的事情有哪些？因为我们总是在宣传这方面做得很糟糕。所以，第一，我将参加一个“问我任何事”（AMA）活动，在下周五，7月2日下午，我不记得具体时间了，但推特上有详细信息。我要做一个“问我任何事”活动，
for the C++ India meetup yeah Connor will put a link in the show notes so come ask me questions about stuff okay C++ India AMA Um, yeah, Connor will put a link in the show notes. So come ask me questions about stuff. Okay. C plus plus India, AMA. Um, I'm not even sure how much of this stuff you, you know, personally. So, uh, I was on my maybe second favorite podcast, uh, co-recursive, uh, which was,
为C++印度聚会。是的，康纳会在节目简介里放一个链接，所以快来问我关于各种事情的问题吧。好吧，C++印度AMA。嗯，是的，康纳会在节目简介里放一个链接。所以快来问我关于各种事情的问题吧。好吧，C++印度，AMA。嗯，我甚至不确定其中有多少事情是你个人知道的。所以，呃，我上了我可能是第二喜欢的播客，Co-recursive，
it was awesome. I talked about the first half was talking about this one. This one obviously is your favorite podcast, right? No. ADSP is your favorite one? No. My own podcast is not my favorite podcast. My favorite podcast is Functional Geekery, which everyone should go listen to. Honestly, at some point I'm probably going to go back and re-listen to all the episodes
这太棒了。我谈到了——前半部分是关于这个播客的。这个显然是你最喜欢的播客，对吧？不是。ADSP是你最喜欢的吗？不是。我自己的播客不是我最喜欢的播客。我最喜欢的播客是Functional Geekery，每个人都应该去听听。老实说，在某个时候我可能会回去重新听所有的节目，
because they're so awesome. But yeah, I was on there. I talked about competitive coding and then APL for the second half um lots of great apl content i have a second podcast now do you know about this i i i i don't and i feel betrayed uh yeah so i'm i'm host of another podcast called arrayraycast. Yeah. And it's a panel podcast. Full disclosure, I don't do any of the editing work for this one. That's Bob Terrio, who's one of the panelists. So basically it's four folks and we rotate some of the co-hosts. So like I'm the host that doesn't know anything.
因为它们太棒了。但是，是的，我上了那个节目。前半部分我谈到了竞技编程，然后后半部分谈到了APL。有很多很棒的APL内容。我现在有了第二个播客。你知道这事吗？我——我——我不知道，而且我觉得被背叛了。呃，是的，所以我——我是另一个名为arraycast的播客的主持人。是的。这是一个小组讨论形式的播客。坦白说，这个节目我没有做任何剪辑工作。剪辑是鲍勃·特里奥（Bob Terrio）做的，他也是小组成员之一。所以基本上是四个人，我们会轮流担任共同主持。所以，比如我是那个什么都不懂的主持人。
And then we usually have one representative for each of apl uh j which is like an apl derivative and then uh q slash k which are also apl derivatives and we just talk about uh array programming language stuff and i'm we're bringing apl back from the dead even though some people would argue it was never dead um wait which people which people would argue it was never dead uh i mean like that are which people that are not named con the people that work for uh dialogue apl that implements the interpreter that many corporations use so there's also who are these who are these mini corporations so simcorp is probably like the largest uh company that they operate in the financial software section so i'll link it um here let me find it uh because i tweeted it out you know i'm not sure if you're familiar that like
然后我们通常会为APL、J（这是一种类似于APL的派生语言）、以及Q/K（它们也是APL的派生语言）各有一名代表，我们只是讨论数组编程语言相关的东西。我们正在让APL死灰复燃，尽管有些人会认为它从未消亡。等等，哪些人？哪些人会认为它从未消亡？我是说，那些——哪些人？不是叫康的那些人。那些为——为Dialogue APL工作的人，他们实现了许多大公司都在使用的解释器。所以，还有，这些是哪些人？这些小公司有哪些？SIMCorp可能是最大的公司，他们在金融软件领域运营。所以我会放个链接，
there's a haskell list companies that use Haskell and like companies that use Elixir. Um, there's now a, and they're usually hosted on, um, on GitHub. There's now a companies that use array languages. Here, let me send this to you.
等我找一下，因为我发了推特。你知道的，我不确定你是否熟悉，就像有一个使用Haskell的公司列表，还有使用Elixir的公司。嗯，现在有一个——它们通常托管在GitHub上。现在有一个“使用数组语言的公司”列表。来吧，我把这个发给你。
It's a short, what is an, what is an array language? Well, to learn that you should go listen to episodes 1, 2, or 0, 1, 2, and 3. Literally, I think there was an episode that just got released today, which is June 25th, and listeners will be listening to this sometime in July. And we talked about, yeah, what's an array?
这是一个简短的……什么是数组语言？嗯，要了解这一点，你应该去听第1、第2集，或者第0、第1、第2和第3集。真的，我想刚好今天——也就是6月25日——刚发布了一集，听众们听到这期节目时大概是在7月份。我们讨论了，是的，什么是数组？
What is the array oriented paradigm but it's basically it's a language that basically only has arrays and um yeah this actually is interesting because i i have a the the what is an array in this context does it imply contiguous storage or is it just a sequence um that's actually discussed so like it depends on the language k it's not always contiguous apparently um k and q they treat their like matrices as uh you know a table of vectors so like a a list of vectors where each of the vectors are, I'll bet that's the thing is I think they're vectors. If I recall Nick,
什么是面向数组的范式？但基本上，它是一种基本上只有数组的语言。嗯，这其实很有趣，因为我有一个——在这个语境下，“什么是数组”？它暗示了连续存储吗？还是仅仅是一个序列？这其实是有讨论的。比如，这取决于语言。比如K，它并不总是连续的，显然。K和Q把它们的矩阵当作——你知道的——向量表，就像一个向量列表，其中每个向量都是——我敢打赌，关键在于我认为它们是向量。如果我没记错尼克（Nick）的话，
what he said is that they are not necessarily homogeneous. So which necessarily implies that you're either going to have to like box them in order to get them contiguous. But in J and APL, they're definitely contiguous. Yeah, I think in C++, the analogy for what an array language is called array is just the notion of a sequence or perhaps thinking a little bit more modern C++, the notion of a range. So when I say a sequence, I mean a sequence as in like what we call the sequence algorithms
他说它们不一定是同构的。这必然意味着你要么必须将它们装箱（boxing）以实现连续存储。但在J和APL中，它们绝对是连续的。是的，我认为在C++中，关于什么是数组语言的类比，数组仅仅是一个序列的概念，或者也许用更现代的C++思维来思考，是范围（range）的概念。所以当我说了序列时，我的意思是像我们在标准库中称为序列算法的那种序列，
in the standard library algorithms that operate on ranges of iterators. And it's an interesting thing to think about because they're, you know, one-dimensional. You know, they go from front to end. They're homogeneous in that they, at least in C++, they have a single type. could, you know, you could through boxing or type erasure, of course, hold things that have different actual types or kinds in a sequence. And, you know, we have this notion of different categories of sequences, which are sort of come from the categories of iterators. And, you know, the most useful from the perspective of somebody implementing the algorithm,
即在迭代器范围上操作的算法。思考这一点很有趣，因为它们是一维的。你知道的，它们从前往后。它们是同构的，至少在C++中，它们具有单一类型。当然，你可以通过装箱或类型擦除（type erasure），在一个序列中容纳具有不同实际类型或种类的对象。而且，你知道，我们有不同类别序列的概念，这些概念某种程度上来自于迭代器的类别。而且，从实现算法的人的角度来看，最有用的是
a sequence algorithm, is, of course, contiguous. Having a guarantee that all the elements of this sequence are that you not only have random access to them, but they're all contiguous in memory. And that's great. If you only have to write an algorithm that works for that, like that's, that's a lot easier. But from from the user perspective, the most useful thing is when an algorithm supports all classes of sequences. And I'd actually be curious whether other languages have the same notions of categories as C++ does. I think things from forward iterator and up probably do map, but do other languages like apl and j do they have a notion of um of input
序列算法，当然是连续的。保证这个序列的所有元素不仅可以随机访问，而且在内存中全部是连续的。这太棒了。如果你只需要编写适用于这种结构的算法，那——那要简单得多。但从用户的角度来看，最有用的是当算法支持所有类别的序列时。其实我很好奇其他语言是否也和C++一样具有相同的类别概念。我想前向迭代器及以上的那些可能可以映射，但其他语言比如APL和J，它们有没有关于——类似于输入迭代器的概念，即你只能递减、你只能解引用一次？
of something like input iterators where you can only decrement you can only dereference it you know once no at least not to my knowledge like apl isL is a much simpler, has like a much simpler model. Just everything's an array. It has a rank 0, 1, 2, 3, to up to like 15 or something, which just specifies the dimensionality. So like a zero. Why up to 15?
没有，至少据我所知没有。APL是一个简单的多的语言，有一个简单得多的模型。一切都是数组。它有秩0、1、2、3，一直到15左右，这仅仅指定了维度。所以像0。为什么最多到15？
I don't know. Why is it arbitrary? I think it's arbitrary. But why isn't it, why doesn't it just like support like any dimensionality? I do not know um i know that there is an implementation of apl in common lisp uh called april that due to the
我不知道。为什么它是任意的？我认为它是任意的。但为什么它不——为什么它不支持任意维度呢？我不知道。嗯，我知道在Common Lisp中有一个APL的实现叫做April，由于
fact that lisp supports like infinite dimensions on like nested lists that there's no limit in that sort of apl implementation implementation called April. But yeah, I'm not really sure what the limit in APL is for. And, you know, I think one of the unfortunate tragedies of C++ is when we built heterogeneous sequences, it stood tuple. We did not build it in a way where we could reuse the same series of algorithmic primitives
Lisp支持嵌套列表上的无限维度，因此在那个名为April的APL实现中是没有这种限制的。但是，是的，我其实不是很确定APL中的限制是用来做什么的。而且，你知道，我认为C++的一个不幸的悲剧是，当我们构建异构序列std tuple时，我们构建它的方式并没有让我们能够对异构序列和同构序列
for both heterogeneous and homogeneous sequences. And I don't know about the rest of y'all, but anytime I end up doing something non-trivial with stood tuples, I end up writing some series of tuple algorithms. And like these just, these just get, some set of these just gets copy and pasted from one project to another project to another project. Like, you know, tuple pushback, tuple
复用同一系列的算法原语。我不知道你们其他人怎么样，但每当我最终用std tuple做一些非平凡的事情时，我最终都会编写一些tuple算法系列。这些算法——其中的某部分就是从一个项目复制粘贴到另一个项目，再到另一个项目。比如，tuple pushback、tuple
pop, et cetera, tuple reverse, a bunch of, a bunch of like little algorithms like that. And, um, and every time I, I do that, I'm just like, why can't I just call the standard algorithms on these? Yeah. Isn't that what Louis Dion's Boost HANA is for? Yeah. Yeah, exactly. That's exactly what it's for. Yeah.
pop等，tuple reverse，一堆——一堆像这样的小算法。而且，嗯，每次我这样做时，我都在想，为什么我不能直接在这些东西上调用标准算法呢？是的。Louis Dionne的Boost HANA不就是为了这个吗？对。对，完全正确。这正是它的用途。是的。
So why aren't you using that, Bryce? Yeah, that's a good question. A lot of the projects that I work with, it's not, you know, I used to work on HPX where we used Boost for everything. And then since I've started working on other things like, you know, Thrust and Cub that Thrust should stand alone, that it shouldn't really have any dependencies. We'll leave aside the fact that it does actually have some dependencies. But his philosophy was it should be super simple to use, and so we should avoid the C++ dependency management problem by not having any dependencies. And amusingly, this doesn't mean that Thrust doesn't use Boost. It just means that the parts of Boost that Thrust really needed to use, Thrust just copied them into Thrust. So like Thrust complex is a very, very, very bastardized derivative of like some boost complex data type.
那布莱斯，你为什么不用那个呢？是的，这是个好问题。我合作的许多项目，它不是——你知道的，我以前在HPX工作，我们在那里对所有东西都使用Boost。然后自从我开始从事其他事情后，比如Thrust和CUB，Thrust应该是一个独立的库，它不应该有任何依赖项。我们先不谈它实际上确实有一些依赖项这件事。但他的哲学是它应该超级简单易用，因此我们应该通过没有任何依赖项来避免C++依赖管理问题。有趣的是，这并不意味着Thrust不使用Boost。这只是意味着Thrust真正需要使用的Boost的那部分，Thrust直接把它们复制到了Thrust里。所以，比如Thrust complex是Boost complex数据类型的一个非常、非常、非常山寨的衍生品。
And same for like the thrusts iteratorcessor layer is derived from HPX's preprocessor layer, which is derived from Boost's preprocessor layer. So the C++ dependency management solution, just copy it into your project. Control C, control V. Yeah. But I do wonder whether, you know, we made a mistake with not making tuple a language construct. I sort of have two different ways of thinking about this. I have both an argument for why it's good that we made it a library construct and an argument for why it was good that we made it a library construct and an argument for why it's, um, uh, why it was maybe a mistake. Um, I'll start with the argument for,
对于Thrust的iterator/accessor层也是如此，它派生自HPX的预处理器层，而HPX又派生自Boost的预处理器层。所以C++依赖管理的解决方案就是：直接复制到你的项目中。Ctrl+C，Ctrl+V。是的。不过我确实在想，我们把tuple做成一个语言结构是不是犯了个错误。我对此有两套不同的思考方式。我既有一个论据支持为什么把它做成库结构是件好事，也有一个论据支持为什么把它做成……呃，为什么把它做成库结构是个错误。嗯，我先从以下论据开始：
for why things should be library, um, constructs in C++, which is, um, uh, I don't want to say regularity because that has a specific meaning in, uh, in, in the notion of types. And so if I use it casually here, it won't express what I want. So I think I'll say familiarity. Good C++ features have familiarity, which means that they sort of follow
为什么在C++中事物应该是库结构，也就是，呃——我不想说“规律性”（regularity），因为这在类型概念中具有特定的含义。如果我在这里随意使用它，它将无法表达我想要的意思。所以我想我会说“熟悉性”（familiarity）。好的C++特性具有熟悉性，这意味着它们某种程度上遵循
some core basic set of rules and they don't have a bunch of caveats. So let's take an example of something that does not follow familiarity, which is built-in C arrays in C++. Built-in C arrays cannot be returned from functions. They have this weird property where they can decay to pointers. And they have a bunch of weird conversion rules around that. And they have this really weird syntax
一组核心的基本规则，并且它们没有一堆注意事项。所以让我们举一个不遵循熟悉性的例子，那就是C++中的内置C风格数组。内置C风格数组不能从函数中返回。它们有一个奇怪的特性，就是它们会退化（decay）为指针。它们围绕这一点有一堆奇怪的转换规则。并且它们有一种非常奇怪的语法，
where when you're declaring a C style array, you know, you put these brackets and like the placement of them is like a little bit quirky. And like sometimes you have to put a, you know, a specific size in there. And then sometimes it can just be like defaulted. And all of that is unfamiliar. And by that, I mean, it's not consistent with the basic like rules of C++ structs. Um, now you compare that to something like std array. So std array is a modern C++, um, uh, abstraction for, you know, the same sort of thing as a C style array. And when you spell out the type for a std array, it uses a familiar syntax, template syntax.
即当你声明一个C风格数组时，你知道，你要加上这些方括号，而且它们的位置有点古怪。有时你必须在其中放入一个特定的尺寸。然后有时它可以直接是默认的。所有这些都是不熟悉的。我的意思是，这与C++结构体（structs）的基本规则不一致。现在，你把它和类似std array的东西做个比较。所以std array是现代C++中用于——类似于C风格数组的抽象。当你拼写std array的类型时，它使用的是熟悉的语法，模板语法。
It doesn't use this weird special syntax where you have to put brackets in a certain place. And so if you know template syntax, how to instantiate a template, then you'll understand that std array syntax. And likewise, std array doesn't have these weird decay rules where it decays to a pointer. You can get a pointer from it by calling a member function. Member functions, that's something that, like if you understand how you call member function, when, like, you understand how you get a pointer from a std array, there's none of this weird conversion rules to
它不使用这种必须把方括号放在特定位置的奇怪特殊语法。所以如果你懂模板语法、如何实例化一个模板，那么你就会理解std array的语法。同样地，std array没有那种会退化为指针的奇怪退化规则。你可以通过调用成员函数从它获取指针。成员函数，那是——如果你理解如何调用成员函数，当——比如，你理解如何从std array获取指针，这里没有任何需要了解的奇怪转换规则。你可以从函数中返回一个std array。这正是你对这种东西的期望。我把行为像这样的东西称为“结构体抽象”（struct abstractions）。C++结构体或C++类的好处在于，它们遵循一组关于你能对它们做什么的通用规则。它们拥有通用且熟悉的语法。所以，你知道，我认为std array是一种比内置C数组好得多的抽象，因为std array遵循几乎与std vector或std string完全相同的规则，它们都是结构体。所以它们都遵循一组非常相似的规则。因此，按照同样的逻辑，std tuple只是另一个结构体，这很好，因为它遵循结构体的一切规则。
know. You can return a std array from a function. Like, that's sort of what you'd expect to be able to do with the thing. And I call things that behave like this, I call them struct abstractions. The nice thing about C++, you know, structs or C++ classes is that there's a common set of rules that they follow about what you can do with them. And they have a common and familiar syntax. And so, you know, I think that std array is a much better abstraction than built-in C arrays because std array follows almost like almost all of the same rules as something like std vector or std string, where they're all structs. And so they all play by, you know, a very similar set of rules. And so in that same logic, like, you know, it's nice that std tuple is, you know, just another struct because it follows all the rules of structs.
这样做的妙处在于，它最大限度地减少了你需要学习的东西数量，以及关于核心语言你需要了解的注意事项的数量。如果我们从来没有内置C数组，如果我们只有std array，那么你就无需学习所有这些注意事项：哦，你可以从函数中返回任何对象，除了内置C数组。那就会变成：你可以从函数中返回任何对象。砰。搞定。同样，你也不必学习指针退化的所有怪异之处以及它对重载的所有影响。
And the reason that this is nice is because it minimizes the number of things that you have to learn, the number of caveats that you have to learn about the core language. You know, if we never had built-in C arrays, if we just had std array, then you wouldn't have to learn all these caveats of, oh, you can return, you know, you can return any object from a function except for built-in C arrays. Then it would just be, you can return any object from a function. Boom. Done. And likewise you wouldn't have to learn all this weirdness with pointer decay and all the implications it has on overloads.
所以我认为，对于类对象的事物而言，最好的C++语言抽象其行为应该像结构体一样，就像它们是库抽象一样。现在，也许我们在std tuple上犯的错误是，
So I think the best C++ language abstractions for object-like things behave like structs, like as if they were library abstractions. Now, perhaps the mistake we made with std tuple
我们弄懂了……我认为我们某种程度上把接口的一些基础部分做对了，我们决定把它做成一个类结构体的抽象。但是活在这些规则之内确实使它的接口变得非常复杂，我认为这阻碍了我们拥有更优雅的东西，比如参数包（parameter packs）的某种广义形式。所以你看处理std tuple时的一些笨拙之处，
was that we got the... I would argue that we sort of got some of the basics of the interface right and that we decided to make it a struct-like abstraction. But living within those rules really complicated its interface and I think prevented us from having something that could have been a lot more elegant, like some generalized form of parameter packs. And so like, you look at some of the unwieldiness of dealing with std
你会想，好吧，这真的值得让它表现得像所有其他类结构体一样所付出的代价吗？你知道的，特别是std get接口，简直有点……在你刚才说这些话的整个过程中，我一直在想，你知道，无论是库特性还是语言特性，就像不得不完整拼写出`std::colon::get`尖括号数字尖括号圆括号，然后是你的tuple类型。是的。嗯，特别是当你把它与其他有元组（tuple）、和类型（sum types）以及模式匹配（pattern matching）和解构（destructuring）等作为语言设施内置的语言进行比较时。是的。
tuple, and you wonder, well, okay, you know, is this really worth the cost of having it behave like all other struct like things? You know, like the std git interface in particular is just kind of... The whole time you've been saying all this, I've just been like, you know, like the std get interface in particular is just kind of... The whole time you've been saying all this, I've just been like, you know, whether it's a library or language thing, it's just like having to spell out std colon colon get angle number angle paren, then your tuple type. Yeah. Um, especially when you compare it to like other languages that have tuples, uh, some types and like pattern matching and destructuring, like all built in as sort of language, um, facilities. Yeah.
当你不得不做诸如“我需要这个元组中的第三个、第三个元素。让我——让我去……”之类的事情时，只会让你感到畏缩。他们叫它什么来着？分号之癌（cancer of the semicolon），嗯，或者诸如此类的事情。相比其他语言，它非常不优雅。而且，如果你仔细看，是的，你知道，它确实很熟悉，但那是付出了代价的。它确实为其他类结构体抽象提供了一种熟悉的语法，但这是有代价的。如果你特别看std get的设计，
It just makes you cringe when you have to like, oh, I need the third, third item from this tuple. Let me, let me go. And what did they call it? Cancer of the semicolon, um um or that kind of thing it's just it's very non-elegant um compared to other languages and and if you look in and yeah and you know like it is familiar but that comes with a cost like it does have a familiar syntax for other struct like abstractions but it comes with a cost. And if you look at the design of std get in particular,
它不是成员函数是有原因的。它不是成员函数的原因是，如果它是成员函数，那么在依赖语境（dependent contexts）中，你就必须编写`.template get`，那简直太惨了。我想它不是成员函数可能还有其他原因，
there's a reason it's not a member function. And the reason it's not a member function is that if it was a member function, then in dependent contexts, you'd have to write.template get, which would have just been atrocious. I think there's probably other reasons why it's not a member function too,
但我认为那是主要原因之一。而且，是的，我认为我们本想要的语法，你知道，就像用于访问包成员的方括号语法。也许我们可以找到一种方法来做到这一点，同时又让tuple仍然是一个类结构体的抽象。也许我们可以通过某种方式扩展语言，以允许接受常量参数的索引运算符。
but I think that was one of the main ones. And yeah, and the syntax that I think we would have wanted, you know, just like a bracket syntax for accessing members of the pack. You know, perhaps we could have found a way to have done that while also having tuple be still a struct-like abstraction. Maybe we could have extended the language in some way to allow an indexing operator that takes a constant parameter.
也许那会是更好的设计。或者也许我们本应该把它作为一个完全内置的语言设施引入。我绝对觉得我们处理Tuple的方式可能并不对。这还不算Tuple的实现负担。Tuple非常难实现。要正确实现它非常困难，
And maybe that would have been a better design. Or maybe we should have just introduced it as a full built-in language facility. I definitely feel like the way that we went about doing Tuple was probably not right. And this is all leaving aside just the implementation burden of Tuple. Tuple's very difficult to implement. It's very difficult to implement correctly um and uh at times it can have you know big compile time or at times if implemented in like uh uh naively it can have big compile
而且有时它可能会带来巨大的编译期开销——或者有时如果实现得比较幼稚，它可能会带来巨大的编译期开销。而且，你知道，我最近看了很多肖恩·巴克斯特（Sean Baxter）的Circle。这确实让我开始质疑我们tuple设计的明智之处他在Circle中处理tuple和参数包的设施要优雅和强大得多，而且它们确实某种程度上满足了我的熟悉性目标，它们看起来就像是语言的自然扩展。是的，这很有趣，因为我查了一下Swift的tuple，为了记录在案，为了所有因为布莱斯错误的发音而感到尴尬的人，我确实有tuple的正确发音，因为斯特凡·拉瓦德（Stephan Lavavej）对此拥有最终裁决权，我相信是这样的。
time costs um and you know i've been looking a lot at uh at sean baxter's Circle recently. And that's really sort of made me question the wisdom of the design of our tuple because the facilities that he has for dealing with tuples and parameter packs in Circle are far more elegant and powerful, and they do actually sort of satisfy my familiarity goal, that they just sort of seem like natural extensions of the language. Yeah, it's interesting, because I looked up Swift's tuple, and for the record, for all those that are cringing because of Bryce's incorrect pronunciation, I do have the correct pronunciation of tuple because Stefan Laowade is the arbiter on this, I believe.
Swift的哲学是尽可能把东西推给标准库。所以如果我没记错的话，他们的整数类型就像是库。它们是在库中实现的，而不是在语言中。所以，你知道，作为一门语言，它的目标之一基本上是尽可能多地让东西在库中实现，这反过来又赋予了语言的使用者和语言的实现者同样强大的能力。话虽如此，我相信从他们的文档来看，他们的tuple类型是一个语言设施。它不是在库中实现的。所以对于一个将此作为目标或信条的语言来说，
Swift's philosophy is to push as much stuff to the standard library as possible. So like if I'm not mistaken, like their integer types are like library. They're implemented in the library, not in the language. So it's, you know, one of its goals as a language is to basically push as much stuff as possible to be implemented in the library, which then gives like users of the language just as much power as like the
这很有趣，因为我原本其实期望Swift的tuple是在库里的，但它看起来并不在。我可能记错了。它确实看起来像是某种足够基础的东西，需要成为语言的一部分。但我认为，我仍然相信对于大多数设施而言，正确的答案是将它们实现为库抽象，因为库抽象具有这种熟悉性。
implementers of the language. And that being said, I believe from looking at their docs, their tuple type is a language facility. It's not implemented in a library. So for a language that like has that as a, as a, as a goal or sort of a tenant it. It's interesting because I was expecting actually
我们可能出错的地方在于，我们没有——我们用当时可用的工具将Tuple构建为一个库抽象，而且我认为我们没有花足够的时间去自问：我们该如何做到——我们怎样才能做出更好的东西？我们在C++中需要什么样的语言设施来制作一个更好的库级tuple？我认为，也许有了正确的工具集，我们本可以制作出一个更好的库级tuple，但是——我的意思是，不管怎样，任何在标准库中的东西，你都得付出那五个字符的税：`std::`，而这有点不幸。好吧，我的意思是，我们现在有了结构化绑定（structured bindings），所以——是的，那——是的，那确实避免了在我们需要它们的许多地方到处使用std get。我依稀记得——你几年前写给我的那篇论文，大意是“哦，我们需要lambda参数列表中的结构化绑定”。
Swift's tuple to be in the library and it does not look like it is. I could be mistaken. It does seem like it's something, it does seem like something that's perhaps fundamental enough that it needs to be part of the language. But I would, I think that I still believe that the right answer for most facilities is to implement them as library abstractions because library abstractions have this familiarity.
是的，然后你说：“哈，为什么这很有用？”然后快进两年，你说：“对，然后尝试——尝试着去……”我想那确实是用笛卡尔积（cartesian product），这是其中的一个——那是用笛卡尔积，我当时想做幻灯片，我想：“如果我没有这个，幻灯片就没那么优雅，我需要这张幻灯片来说服大众——HPC大众——C++标准并行性才是前进的方向。”所以现在，康纳，是的，我关心你的东西，把那个东西拿给我！严格来说，有篇论文——我会在节目简介里放个链接——是几年前的，但它夭折了，当时叫做“泛型lambda与结构化绑定”或者类似的名字。但是，是的，我希望你复活它，好吗？但是，是的，正如我刚才所说的那样，关于那五个字符的税，我只是在想，有了返回值推导、
The place where I think we may have gone wrong is that we did not – we built Tuple as a library abstraction with the tools that we had available and i don't think we spent enough time asking ourselves how could we have how could we make a better like what language facilities would we need to make a better library tuple in c++ and i think that that perhaps with with the right set of tools we could have made a better library tuple but um i mean but you you still you know anything that's in the standard library you're gonna have to pay that um that five character tax stood colon colon and that is a little bit unfortunate well i mean we have structured bindings now so uh yeah that that yeah that does avoid stood get many times we need them everywhere though you i finally remember i i you gotta write me that paper a couple years ago was like oh we need we need structured bindings in lambda uh lambda uh parameter
自动返回值推导，以及诸如结构化绑定之类的东西，你其实并不真的——它实际上并不会在很多地方出现。而且结构化绑定真的很有趣，因为它们——我认为它们极大地改变了我们设计API的方式。举个例子，我最近花了很多时间的事情之一就是在C++中推进执行器（executors）的工作。在最新的提案中，有一个叫做“发送者”（sender）的概念，它可以发送值，并且可能发送多个值。所以这被表示为一个tuple。
lists yeah and then you were like huh why is that useful and then fast forward two years and you were like yeah then trying to try to i think it was literally with cartesian product which is one of the it was with cartesian product and i was i was i wanted to make slides and i was like if i don't have this the slide is less elegant and i need this slide to convince to convince the masses the the hbc masses that uh c++ standard parallelism is the way to go so now connor yes i care about your thing bring me bring me that thing technically there was a paper i'll link it in the show notes from a few years ago but it died it was called like generic lambdas and yeah generic lambdas with structure bindings or something like that but yeah but i want you to revive it okay but um but yeah i was just as i was saying that about you know the five character tax i was just thinking you know with um with return
通常你不会看到这个tuple，因为通常这些多个值被具体化的方式是作为多个函数参数。所以通常情况下，如果你在构建异步工作链，你通常不会看到这个tuple。只是，嘿，你有一个函数接受三个参数，而发送的tuple被解包并作为这三个函数参数传入。但在链的末端，当你等待该异步工作链时，你将获得最终结果。这将使tuple具体化。
type deduction with automatic return type deduction, with automatic return type deduction and with things like structured bindings, you don't really actually, it doesn't actually really come up that many places. And structured bindings are really interesting because, um, they, I think they change a lot about how we design APIs. Um, an example, one of the things I've spent a lot of time on recently has been shepherding the executor's effort in C++. And in the latest proposal, there's this notion of a thing called a sender that can send values and it can send potentially multiple values. And so that is represented as a tuple.
所以有一个函数`sync_wait`，你给它一个sender，它会返回该sender发送给你的值。它会一直阻塞，直到该sender完成并发送了它的值。而这个`sync_wait`返回什么？嗯，它必须返回一个tuple，因为sender可能会发送多个值。而且我们实际上可以相当优雅地做到这一点，即使在发送单个值的简单情况下也是如此。因为在发送单个值的简单情况下，你只需写`auto [a] = sync_wait(...)`，不管是什么sender。
Usually you don't see the tuple because typically the way that those multiple values get materialized is as multiple function parameters. So usually the thing that, you know, if you're building a chain of asynchronous work, you don't usually see the tuple. It's just that, hey, you have a function that takes, you know, three parameters and the tuple gets, you know, the tuple that's sent gets unpacked and passed in as those three function parameters. But at the end of the chain, when you're waiting for that chain of asynchronous work, then you're getting back the final result. And that is going to materialize the tuple.
现在，想象一个没有结构化绑定的世界。在那个没有结构化绑定的世界里，编写那个简单的用例将要求你改写成`auto a = std::get(这个sync_wait表达式)`。而且我认为，如果我们没有结构化绑定，如果那个简单的用例必须涉及那个`std::get`调用，我想我们可能会完全不同地设计那个函数。我们可能会说，“我们要约束这个`sync_wait`函数，只接受发送单个值的sender，这样我们就可以直接返回该值。这样我们就不用为这个简单的用例写这种可怕的语法了。”但由于有了结构化绑定，我们可以为简单的用例编写这种优雅的代码，并且它能够非常优雅地扩展到更复杂的用例。
And so there's this function sync weight, which you give it a sender, and it returns to you the value that that sender is sent. And it will block until that sender has completed and sent its value. And what does that sink weight return? Well, it has to return a tuple because the sender might send multiple values. And we can actually kind of do that quite elegantly, even in the simple case of a single value being sent. Because in that simple case of a single value being sent, you just write auto, open bracket, you know, a, close bracket, equals, sink weight, whatever, the sender.
所以很有趣的是，哦，结构化绑定只是语法糖（syntax sugar）。但我认为这个语法糖彻底改变了我们会如何设计这个API，以及我们认为对于这个API什么才是可接受的解决方案。如果没有结构化绑定，我认为这个API返回一个`std::tuple`是不可接受的。是的，这里有——
Now, imagine a world before structured bindings. In that world before structured bindings, writing that simple case would have required you to instead say auto a equals std get zero of this sink weight expression. And I think that if we didn't have structured bindings, if that simple case had to involve that std get call, I think we probably would have designed that function completely differently. We might have said, you know, we're going to constrain this sink weight function to only accept senders that send a single value so that we can just return that value directly. So we don't have to have this horrible syntax for this simple case. But because of structured bindings, we can write this sort of elegant, you know, code for the simple case. And it extends pretty elegantly for the
有两个短语，怎么说呢，不是说它们令人恼火，而是它们完全模糊了——比如某事的重要性。其中之一就是“这只是语法糖”。因为就像lambda只是语法糖，但它完全改变了人们使用算法的方式，以及触及算法并定制其行为的难易程度。所以说这只是语法，
more complex cases. And so it's interesting that, oh, structured bindings is just syntax trigger. But I think that that syntax trigger completely changed how we would have designed this API and what we would have thought was an acceptable solution for this API. I don't think it would have been acceptable for this api to have returned a stud tuple um if not for structured bindings yeah there's there's
就好像是在说，“好吧，一切都只是语法糖。这一切都只是编写汇编语言的语法糖。”而另一个让我更生气的短语是当有人说“这只是语义”（It's just semantics）。而我当时就想：“你明白自己在说什么吗？这只是我们附加到词语上的含义，我们在进行沟通。一切都是语义。如果我们不——”我从没听过有人这么说。哦，对，他们会说，“哦，这只是语义，无所谓啦（tomato tomato）”——这其实不是语义，那是同一个词的两种不同发音。
two phrases that sort of i don't not the word is not irritate but just like completely obfuscates um like the importance of something uh one of them is just like syntax sugar because like lambdas are just syntax sugar, but it completely changes the way that like people use algorithms and how easily it is to reach for an algorithm and customize its behavior. So like saying it's just syntax,
是的，这就好比“哦，好吧，你对这个词的理解略有不同，我是这个意思……”而这就好像，“好吧，你不能只说‘这只是语义’。”这导致了我们完全的误解。我想凯夫林·汉尼（Kevlin Henney）说过这话。他在一次演讲中说过：“是的，”他说，“人们会说‘这只是语义’，而这就好比是字面意义上最重要的事情。如果我说了一个词，而你脑海中有不同的定义，我们就会遇到麻烦。”
it's just like, okay. Everything's just syntax sugar. Like it's all just syntax sugar for like writing assembly. And the other one that irritates me even more is when someone says it's just semantics. And I'm just like, you realize what you're saying, right? It's just the meanings that we attach to the words and we're communicating. Like it's everything is semantics. Like if we don't. I've never heard somebody say that. Oh, yeah. They say, oh, it's everything is semantics like if we don't i've never heard
他是我们应该请到节目上来的人，我敢打赌他是另一个能讲很多精彩的“围坐在火堆旁听我讲故事”的人。是的，我们绝对应该。凯夫林·汉尼不可能——不是不可能，他听这个播客的概率非常低。但如果你正在听，凯夫林，来吧，来吧！你知道，还有另一个特性，我认为经常被诋毁，但实际上证明非常棒，那就是类模板参数导引（CTAD）。任何关注我的推特或关注我过去几个月一直在做的事情的人
somebody say that oh yeah they say oh it's just semantics you know tomato tomato which is actually not semantics that's two different uh pronunciations of the same word um yeah it's like oh well you just had a slightly different interpretation of the word and i meant it this way and it's like well you can't just say it's just semantics. That led to like our complete misunderstanding. I think Kevin Henney has said that. He said that in a talk once is that, yeah, he's like, oh, you know, people say it's just semantics. And it's like, that's literally like the most important thing. If I say one word and you have a different definition in your head, we're going to have a problem.
都知道我对它感到非常兴奋，特别是在`mdspan`提案的背景下，我实际上是在2015年加入委员会，以期将类似`mdspan`提案的东西引入C++。六年过去了，但我离实现这个目标越来越近了。但在`mdspan`提案中，同时支持静态大小和动态大小的范围。而且，你知道，这意味着编写一些简单的用例，比如我想要一个表示三维矩阵的`mdspan`，比你希望的要冗长一些。因为你必须拼写出这组相当复杂的模板参数，比如你必须写`mdspan`，左尖括号，`double, extents`，然后关闭。这真的很令人不快。然后我意识到，
He's somebody we should have on the show because I bet he's another guest that will have some pretty good come sit around the fire and hear me stories. Yeah, we should definitely. There's no way Kevlin Henning. There's not no way. There's a very low probability that he listens to this podcast. But if you're listening, Kevlin come on come on you know there's another feature which i think is often maligned but is actually proven to be quite great which is a class template argument deduction anybody who's been following me on twitter or following what i've been working on the past
就在几个月前，嘿，等等，有了CTAD，我们可以做到让你永远不必真正拼写出那个类型。在几乎所有情况下，你都可以让这些参数从构造函数参数中推导出来，这会让接口变得干净得多。是的，所以一直在致力于此。而且它再次成为这样一个例子：这种所谓的“语法糖”是如何改变设计的。这是一个巨大的改进，几年前我们对`mdspan`提案做过的一个设计更改——为了优化一个简单的用例，那个设计更改是将`mdspan`做成一个模板别名（template alias），这使得简单的用例稍微容易拼写一些。然后我们还有另一个叫做`basic_mdspan`的东西，它有一个更复杂的模板接口来拼写更复杂的用例。我某种程度上意识到，嘿，有了CTAD，我们把简单的用例做得足够简单，以至于我们不需要为这个东西准备两个不同的名字和两套不同的模板参数。我们可以直接摆脱它。我为此说服了库演进小组的其他成员。我认为这是另一个例子：
couple months knows that i'm very excited about it, in particular in the context of the MD-SPAN proposal, which I actually joined the committee in 2015 to get something like the MD-SPAN proposal into C++. It's six years later, but I'm getting closer to delivering on that goal. But in the MD-SPAN proposal, there's this support for both static and dynamically sized extents. And, you know, that meant that writing out some simple cases like I want an MD span that represents, you know, a three-dimensional matrix was a bit more verbose than you might like. Because you'd have to spell out this like fairly complex set of template parameters like you'd have to do like md span you know left angle bracket double comma extents dynamic underbar extent comma dynamic underbar extent comma dynamic underbar you know close it was it was really unpleasant and then i realized
通过语言创新，我们能够改进我们的库设计。因为，你知道，我们关心的是为事物提供简单直观的语法。当我们获得让语法变得简单直观的新方法时，这就会改变我们设计事物的方式。是的。老实说，你刚才所说的这些，是我非常喜欢APL的部分原因，比如事物外观的优雅性，
like a few months ago hey wait a wait a second, with CTAD, we can make it so that you never really have to spell that out. Like you can, in almost all cases, you can just have those parameters be inferred from the constructor arguments and it'll just make the interface so much cleaner. And yeah, and so I've been working on that. And it just, like, again, it's an example of how this, quote, syntax sugar changed the
你正在构建的表达式或你正在编写的代码片段，它会影响最终结果。就像，auto也是一样，你知道，过去当你必须声明一个向量的迭代器时，你知道，`std::vector::iterator`——
design. It was such an improvement that one design change that we had made to the MD-SPAN proposal a few years ago to make it to like optimize for a simple use case, which that design change was we made MD-SPAN a template alias that made the simple use case a little bit easier to spell. And then we had this other thing called basic MD-SPAN, which had a more complicated template interface for spelling out the more complicated use cases. And I sort of realized, hey, with CTAD, we make the simple use case simple enough that we don't need to have like this two separate names for this thing and two separate sets of template parameters. Like we can just get rid of that. And I convinced the rest of Library Evolution on that. And I think that's another
`type::iterator`，这简直是荒谬绝伦。然后能够用auto替换它，我不知道，它完全改变了可读性和优雅性。而且可读性是代码可维护性的一个重要推动因素，它能让未来的你或其他人在短时间内理解该代码在做什么。是的，很大程度上——如果你想称之为语法糖，或者只是我们用来表达算法或代码的东西，无论你正在解决什么问题，
example of, you know, hey, through language innovation, we're able to improve our library design. Because, you know, we care about having simple intuitive syntaxes for things. And when we get new ways to make syntax simple and intuitive, that then changes how we design things. Yeah. This is honestly like what you just said. It's part of my reason, like a part of the reason why I love APL so much is like the elegance of what something looks like,
表达力都是如此重要。因此，这些小事情，如果你能移除冗余的东西——你知道，在Java中，我想直到现在，你仍然经常需要两次声明类型，这以前在C++中也是如此——现在C++核心指南中有一条核心准则，那就是“只要类型是冗余的并且你在同一行中拼写了两次，就始终使用auto”。无论如何，APL中就是有这样一种纯粹性，
what your expression that you're building up or your piece of code that you're writing, like it affects like the end result. Like, you know, same thing with auto, you know, like in the past when you had to declare, you know, the iterator on a vector, you know, std colon vector angle type angle, colon colon, you know, iterator. Like type angle, colon, colon, you know,
它只有原语，而且非常纯粹。每当有归约（reduction）时，你总是会看到一个斜杠。而在C++中，这被隐藏了，你知道，你必须识别出min函数。
iterator, like, that's just, that's just like, it's ridiculous. And then being able to replace that, like, with auto, I don't know, it just it completely changes, like the readability, the elegance. And like, and readability is, is an important contributor to like maintainability of code and like, you know, future you or future other person being able to like quickly comprehend what that code is doing. And yeah, like so much of like, you know, if you want to call it syntax sugar or just like, you know, what we're using to express the algorithm or the code, you know, whatever problem you're solving, you know, whatever problem you're solving,
迭代器，真的，那太荒谬了。然后能够用 auto 来替换它，我不知道，它完全改变了代码的可读性和优雅性。而且，可读性是代码可维护性的一个重要贡献因素，比如未来的你或者未来的其他人能够快速理解该代码正在做什么。是的，如果你想把它叫做语法糖，或者只是我们用来表达算法或代码的东西，无论你正在解决什么问题，
you know, expressiveness is so important. And so these little things that if you can, if you can remove something that was redundant, you know, in Java, I think still, you end up a lot of the times, and this was previously in C++, like you've got the, you have to state the type twice. And now it's like a core guideline in the whatever C++ core guidelines is like always use auto whenever the type's redundant and you're spelling it twice
表达能力是非常重要的。所以这些小事情，如果你能移除一些冗余的东西，在 Java 中我想依然如此，很多时候——这以前在 C++ 中也是这样——你必须声明两次类型。现在，C++ 核心指南中的一条核心准则就是：当类型是冗余的且你在同一行中写了两次时，总是使用 auto
in the same line. And anyways, there's just this like, you know, there's this purity to APL that like, it's just, all it is is like the primitives and it's so pure. And like whenever there's a reduction you always see a slash and uh like in in c plus plus that's hidden you know you have to recognize that min
不管怎样，APL有一种纯粹性，就是，它全部都是基元，它是如此纯粹。每当有约减（reduction）操作时，你总是能看到一个斜杠，而在 C++ 中，那是隐藏的，你必须识别出 min
element and stood accumulate and find if you know they're all specializations of uh you know they're all reductions but it just you just have to recognize it. And the same thing with like accumulate and partial sum. Those are, those are sibling algorithms. You know, one is the incremental results on the way to getting the final reduction. And that's completely obfuscated by the names of those algorithms. And yeah, there's, there's a lot to be said about, you know, over time, C++ is becoming a much, much like the slideware like that you can write now with CTAD and auto and structure bindings. You can actually get like someone once commented on one of my talks that like my C++ code looks very Pythonic. And I was like, that's not a bad thing. thing like well in in one of the you know i i think i think that ctad and concepts have
元素，然后累加并找出，如果你知道它们都是某种特化，你知道它们其实都是归约（reduction），但你只需要识别出这一点。对于 accumulate 和 partial sum 也是一样的。它们是同胞算法。你知道，其中一个是通往最终归约的累积中间结果。而这完全被这些算法的名称给混淆了。而且，关于这一点有很多话要说，随着时间推移，C++ 变得越来越像你可以通过 CTAD、auto 和结构化绑定编写的幻灯片代码。你实际上可以——曾有人在我的一个演讲中评论说，我的 C++ 代码看起来非常像 Python。我当时就想，这并不是一件坏事。就像，嗯，在其中一个，我—我认为 CTAD 和 concepts 有
are sort of like the next step in the expressivity that we got out of um out of auto because the the downside of auto is there are some cases where maybe solely for readability or documentation not because it's like significant but like you just like you want it to be clear in the code that this is that this thing is an integral or this thing is a vector you know that this locally declared variable you know is an integral or a thing is a vector. You know, this locally declared variable, you know, is an integral or a vector, not necessarily something that's a parameter. But like to me, that's really the value of auto. Like I don't, I do use, I guess I'm not a strict adher, like almost always auto. I'll use auto where it like increases readability. But I really love using CTAD because it lets me get a lot of the benefits of auto while also still making it clear what, making it clear what kind of thing this object is in a line, like in some particular like local declaration, like that can be really, that can be really useful.
某种程度上可以说是我们从 auto 中获得的表达能力的下一步，因为 auto 的缺点在于，在某些情况下，可能仅仅出于可读性或文档说明的目的，而不是因为它的重要性，但你就是希望代码中能清楚地表明这个东西是一个整数，或者这个东西是一个向量。你知道的，这个局部声明的变量是一个整数，或者这个东西是一个向量。你知道的，这个局部声明的变量是一个整数或向量，不一定非得是某个参数。但对我来说，这确实是 auto 的价值所在。我不——我用，我想我并不是一个严格的拥护者，几乎总是用 auto。我会在它能提高可读性的地方使用 auto。但我真的很喜欢使用 CTAD，因为它让我获得了 auto 的很多好处，同时还能在一行代码（比如某个特定的局部声明）中清楚地表明这个对象的类型是什么，这真的非常、非常有用。
Just like solely as documentation. I mean, there are cases, you know, where I really, you know, I really don't care what it is, where sure, I can just write auto and that's fine. But this gives you more options without having to be completely verbose. That's the advantage of CTAD. And I think one of the advantages of concepts is that I can avoid verbosely spelling out the entire type of a thing, but also still, you know, describe some of the properties of this declaration. Yeah. I have yet to use concepts like as a, uh, qualifier on a variable type, if that's what you're talking about. Yeah. I mean, it's, it's, it's, I, I find myself using them a lot when I'm in pseudocode, when I'm communicating with others. I am not in a place where I can use them in work code quite yet.
仅仅作为文档说明。我的意思是，在某些情况下，我真的不在乎它是什么，这种情况下我可以直接写 auto，这没问题。但这就给了你更多的选择，而不需要完全啰嗦。这就是 CTAD 的优势。我认为 concepts 的优势之一在于，我可以避免冗长地拼出一个东西的整个类型，但同时又可以描述这个声明的一些属性。是的。我还没有把 concepts 用作变量类型的限定符，如果你说的是那个的话。是的。我的意思是，当我写伪代码、与他人交流时，我发现自己经常使用它们。我还不能在工作代码中使用它们。
I mean, there are some places where I can. But certainly, whenever I'm just workshopping code with somebody, I'll just default to using concepts. And interestingly, I also will default to using the abbreviated template syntax where you can declare a template function just by using like auto in one of the parameters. And I was one of the people that was a skeptic
我的意思是，在某些地方我可以。但当然，每当我和别人一起讨论代码时，我就会默认使用 concepts。有趣的是，我还会默认使用简化的模板语法（abbreviated template syntax），你可以通过在其中一个参数中使用 auto 来声明一个模板函数。我曾经是怀疑论者之一
about abbreviated template syntax because I was a little bit concerned about the implications of being able to write template functions that were not obviously template functions. But I'm sort of a full convert. Bjarne was completely right about that. And yeah, and I want, I mean, I think that the compromise solution that we have, we're
关于简化模板语法，因为我有点担心编写不是显式模板函数的模板函数会带来什么影响。但我现在可以说是完全被说服了。Bjarne 在这一点上完全是正确的。是的，我希望，我的意思是，我认为我们拥有的折中方案是，我们
sort of the auto has to appear in the parameter list. It's not like you can just have the concept name. You have to have the concept name then followed by auto. I think that was a good compromise because it still gives you an easy way to identify that something's a template but uh i think even if we'd gone the other route of just you know solely concept name makes it a template i think that probably would have been fine just just based on how you use useful i've found it to be and how natural it is yeah it's still i feel like people would have up, because how do you tell if something's
类似于 auto 必须出现在参数列表中。并不是说你可以只写 concept 名称。你必须先写 concept 名称，然后跟上 auto。我认为这是一个很好的折中方案，因为它仍然为你提供了一种简单的方法来识别某个东西是一个模板，但是，我认为即使我们走了另一条路，也就是仅仅通过 concept 名称就能使其成为一个模板，考虑到我发现它有多么有用以及它是多么自然，那可能也没问题。是的，我仍然觉得人们会提出异议，因为你怎么能分辨出某个东西是
an explicit type or a concept if there's no way? I feel like many code bases would end up like, you know. We could have done that by convention. Exactly, yeah. But the committee made what I still believe is a big mistake in that we decided to give standard library concepts snake case names instead of the camel case names that we had been using informally in the community for a long time and that we'd been using in the standard spec to denote name sets of type requirements pre-concepts. And I think that we should have used,
显式类型还是 concept，如果没有别的方法的话？我觉得许多代码库最终会变成这样。我们本可以通过约定来做到这一点。确实如此。但委员会做出了一项我至今仍认为是大错特错的决定，那就是我们决定给标准库 concepts 赋予蛇形命名法（snake_case）的名称，而不是我们在社区中非正式使用了很长时间、并且在标准规范中用来表示概念要求名称集的驼峰命名法（camelCase）。我认为我们本应该使用，
like I think if we had in the standard library used camel case names to the concept names, it would have established that as being the precedent for other standard library-like things. Code bases that use camel case for, and not snake case for like all of their other things, they wouldn't have had a good solution here. i i rolled some os violin for those code bases sorry i shouldn't get all cub yeah yeah one of your two libraries not but that's not by my choice um uh but uh
就像我认为如果我们在标准库中对 concept 名称使用驼峰命名法，它就会成为其他类似标准库事物的先例。那些对所有其他东西都使用驼峰命名法而不是蛇形命名法的代码库，在这里就不会有很好的解决方案了。我为那些代码库拉响了最小的小提琴（表示假装同情），抱歉，我不该这么情绪化的。是的，你的两个库之一，但这并非我的选择，但是……
i i shouldn't uh i shouldn't pretend that i don't have sympathy for a variety of coding styles. I'm just being cute there. I, of course, care about all coding styles. My point is that we could have potentially done this by convention. But I do think that the best convention is the one that we have, which is where the convention is part of the language itself, that there has to be that auto keyword following it. I think that was a really great, a great compromise. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不应该假装我对各种编码风格没有同情心。我刚才只是在卖萌。我当然关心所有的编码风格。我的观点是，我们本可以通过约定来实现这一点。但我确实认为最好的约定就是我们现在拥有的这种，即约定本身就是语言的一部分，后面必须跟那个 auto 关键字。我认为这是一个非常棒的折中方案。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢这期节目，祝你今天过得愉快。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。